c'est une tradition dont la droite
parisienne se passerait bien
mais une fois encore elle partira
divisée dans le département capitale il
y a d'abord la liste officiellement
investi par les républicains menée par
pierre charon
pierre charon élu en 2000 noms sur une
liste dissidente
alors cette année il a le parti avec lui
est impossible de rater l'information
avec le siège de la rue de vaugirard sur
ces photos de campagne sur sa liste
figure un autre sarkozyste historique
l'ancien directeur de la police
nationale frédéric péchenard qui tentera
d'être élu en troisième position suis
très heureux d'être sur la liste
officielle des républicains c'est ce que
je souhaitais et je suis très heureux
d'être à l'aise de pierre charon qui est
un sénateur de qualité et qui est depuis
trente ans un mes amis donc je suis
doublement content de cette place et de
cette position sur cette liste dans un
party by lisez pierre charon tente de
rassembler avec une liste pas uniquement
sarkozyste paris n'est pas le petit
canard boiteux puisque dans tous les
départements il ya des dissidences et un
effet macro qui est arrivé on a perdu la
moitié de nos députés
là maintenant le thème c'est de garder
le sénat donc pour garder le sénat on
peut plus s'amuser à jouer perso il faut
jouer groupé c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire l'ex et east
composée de 14 personnes issues de
toutes les familles de la primaire face
à lui kirchart on trouvera une figure
bien connue de la droite sénatoriale
puisque philippe dominati est lui en
dissident en 2004 puis sur la liste
officielle en 2011 souhaite repartir
pour un troisième mandat dans une droite
qui tente de se reconstruire
on sent que les grands électeurs veulent
savoir où se trouve le sénateur sortant
est ce qu'il ya une question sur nous
l'imposent pour la présidence du parti
j'écoute pas là pour moi c'est prématuré
moi je suis pas tellement un homme de
parti tu sais très bien la preuve
puisque généralement je m'en a franchi
quasiment assurés d'obtenir un siège il
tentera d'emporter un deuxième pour
envoyer un signal aux instances
nationales
ce serait vraiment le signal de la
volonté des élus parisiens de la droite
et du centre de marquer leur
appartenance est un projet qui est un
projet parisien
parce qu'ils ont haché de la mainmise
d'un certain nombre de partis politiques
qui considèrent que paris c'est une
sorte de réserve indienne où on va
parachuté pour reclasser quelqu'un de
l'appareil parce qu'elle a rendu des
services ou ceci ou cela mais l'objectif
est élevé d'autant qu'une troisième
liste issue des rangs et l'air et dans
la course
accompagné du maire du 1er
arrondissement jean françois legaret
catherine dumas est venu comme promis de
déposer sa liste en préfecture
et oui aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour
c'est une étape dans notre campagne et
puis après mais il y aura encore quinze
jours de travail acharné pour gagner
sénatrice de 2007 à 2011 elle avait raté
d'un cheveu sa réélection il ya six ans
la faute en partie à la dissidente de
pierre charon
depuis cet échec elle n'a pas lâché ses
thèmes de prédilection que sont les
métiers d'art et du luxe il s'appuie sur
ces dossiers pour tenter de ravir des
sièges à la haute assemblée
aujourd'hui je considère que je suis
légitime et que ma légitimité et les
basé non pas sur une commission
d'investiture mais sur mes compétences
et sur mon travail
la bataille fait donc rage à droite avec
trois listes menées par des élus y ont
déjà une expérience au palais du
luxembourg
d'autant qu'il faudra encore une fois
compter sur la liste centriste menée par
yves pozzo di borgo et l'ue depuis 2004
il devra pour cette fois faire sans les
voix du modem parti rejoindre la
république en marche et mes amis du
modèle kate avec margot
au sénat d'ailleurs puisque nous sommes
un groupe commun qui est également au
plus près de paris ont préféré choisir
le propre stratégie
je peux pas leur en vouloir parce que et
aux dernières présidentielles il s'est
passé des choses des changements
importants et donc chacun a choisi sa
logique politique et pour s'en sortir il
compte bien défendre la refonte du grand
paris un dossier sur lequel il est très
engagé
on ne peut pas continuer à voir dans
l'île de france des villes des
établissements publics une métropole ses
troupes c'est pas possible et
départements il faudra bien qu'on ait le
courage civil est de refaire une
architecture de l'île de france dans ce
que la logique du grand paris mais ça
pour moi c'est quelque chose de
prioritaire arrêté l'émiettement des
responsabilités une devise qui pourrait
s'appliquer au centre droit et à la
droite parisienne dans sa diversité
les résultats du 24 70 diront si la
stratégie du chacun pour soi a été
payante ou non